my name is Maryann Lorenz I'm 28 years
old and I'm the master taster for
brown-forman
and what's the reason we're responsible
for what the product tastes like on the
shelf I started my career as a chemical
engineer I got hired at brown-forman
actually as an intern in their research
and development group I always thought
I'd be doing renewable energy or
something like that when I was thinking
about all the things that I could make
with corn why in the world would you
make feel with it when you can make
bourbon
the biggest misconception I think is how
do I keep from getting drunk or do I
have to take a taxi home every day
that's not even close to what I do we
have the huge focus on responsibility
there is a time where the lining of your
mouth just goes completely numb and you
can't fight that even if you're not
swallowing you just can't taste anything
physically so you have to give it time
you've to drink water
bourbon is very different from wine and
it has some similar characteristics it's
a whole lot higher alcohol percentage so
you have to train yourself to look past
the burn past the alcohol and it's less
I think that's probably the biggest
difference because we're always looking
at the color nosing and then tasting so
it's a similar process that you go
through I think it's a big influence pop
culture magazines TV show bringing back
a classic cocktail is a cool again it
really is and the rise of mixologist
they want to make those historical basis
cocktail when I tell people that I'm the
brown-forman master taster two things
usually happen their eyes either light
up or they get a little bit confused you
know I know that I don't look like your
typical bourbon professionals but you
know women always embrace me they love
the fact that I'm in the industry and
the position that I am everybody always
wants to know where do they put their
resume in